so alright let's start with we're going
to talk about the regressive left and
the all right which one you would you
prefer to start with what feels like a
better transition there you mean like
what I'd like to start yeah you want to
go regressive laughter all right first
oh let's do the other yeah okay yeah
let's do it
so let's do because actually it Russia
is a good kind of segue to the layout
right because I think that a lot of
people are melt right have this you know
put some cold yeah okay so how would you
just give me your of course a lot of
them are I think are just crumbling
really right there's a lot of trolls on
the order and we know that but what is
what is your definition of the all right
what is the all right to you cuz I think
nobody's defining it properly so
everyone everyone uses it for their own
right for their own purpose right well
it's a little it's difficult to define
actually because there probably isn't a
single right
I mean it's started maybe five or six
years ago with a bunch of people on
really obscure websites and there are
these different kind of factions of they
all rights some of which they're like
there's the and I haven't really written
about the whole neo reactionary
so-called a phenomenon which is really
about kind of going back to pre
democracy political institutions you
know a lot of them are very Pro monarchy
which is kind of a non-starter and they
know it's not but I think today what
people would people refuse your referred
to when they talk about the outright is
it's more kind of white nationalist
segment and I think that has primarily
come to be associated right especially
with the
the Trump campaign which you know the
alt riot has been kind of a affiliate oh
yeah way so Chris Oh correct me if I'm
wrong but my take on it has been that
when people refer to the alt-right yeah
they're referring to this white
nationalist group of people and these
neo-nazis and that thing my feeling
about it from what I've seen just being
online and talking to people and seeing
what people send me and things is that a
huge percentage of the all right
is just really disaffected people who
love memes and they love [ __ ] posting
and saying Nazi imagery to people and
all this stuff not because they're Nazis
but they're so frustrated with the
system that they're just trying to get a
reaction
now I'm not apologizing for them and I
don't like getting those things I
wouldn't stop them showing as long as
they're not trying to physically harm
anybody but I to me the white
nationalist subset of it obviously
exists but it actually strikes me as a
small portion of a movement that really
is just pissed at conservatives you know
that better pissed at the people on the
right who didn't do the things they said
they were going to do they're pissed at
the system they're pissed at the media I
mean a lot of the things that I actually
do care about yet there is absolutely a
truly xenophobic component to it that
doesn't like black people that doesn't
like Muslims gays Jews right right if
you think that's fair to say that
there's some well you know it's really
difficult to estimate the percentages
because it's not like it's not a
movement where you can do a poll and
right now find out what percentage of
people who are affiliated will they
outright online are actually just sort
of disaffected conservatives all over
Tarin's who you know like names and you
know like shitposting or or former
living yeah yeah as opposed to you know
actual white nationalists or you know
even neo-nazis we don't even know how
many people are actually involved
because a lot of them could be like one
person with 30 handles yet could be like
what was that guy's name Joshua Goldberg
remember this was the Jewish guy who had
all these different identity
including including a Nazi oh yeah this
is an amazing story and I actually he
eventually got arrested
he's in a South Park I don't know if
you're watching but I know I know
no but he eventually got arrested I
think for trying to stage some kind of
terrorist act like he was talking to
some radical Muslims online also and I
think he was trying to persuade them
that he was a radical Muslim - and this
guy was just trolling everybody so he
was trying everyone but he had some
personas that really were you know that
we're all right and said yeah we could
be you know dealing with you don't know
you know you never really know we're
dealing what you know you could be
dealing with a teenager who's you know
sitting in his parents preferable
basement right there you know and
pretending to be like 10 or 15 different
people on Twitter so then what I make of
the of the supposed strength at that
like in Hillary when Hillary calls out
the all right yeah are we talking about
an actual political movement here or is
something of a political movement I mean
we know that there are these that there
are people what websites like to feed
their you know those are real people
those are not you know a teenager is
pretending to be somebody you know from
their parents basement yeah now how much
following do they actually have again
nobody knows but I do think that there's
a real movement there I think that they
are gaining a lot of visibility recently
and it's kind of it's really difficult
to even know how to deal with us because
in a way of course by criticizing them
you know these were like me are giving
them more disability right at the same
time I do quite I feel that it is
important to and I really hate the word
call out because it's been so thoroughly
kind of you know appropriated uh you
know misused by the social justice
people but I do think that it's
important to you know point to this and
say yeah you know this is really going
on and this is not a good thing and I
think that there are young people who do
kind of tend to get drawn in by this
stuff for real you know we have a lot of
young
people who are extremely uneducated you
know and I think that is a problem with
the educational system we have a problem
of kind of teaching relativism in the
sense that oh well you know there's
really no such thing as objective truth
and I think people have been there are
people have been saying for a long time
you know those kind of mindset
eventually leads to embracing Holocaust
denial because hey you know who's to say
what really happened if there was you
know if truth is really you know
historical truth is really only just a
matter of who gets to control a
narrative you know right that seemed to
be calm because that's whoever yells I
mean just yesterday did you see this guy
at the Trump rally screaming about it
Holocaust Island it's like I didn't
retweet it because I don't want to
amplify these crazy people yeah and yet
at the same point they've suddenly found
a voice not Trump yeah and I don't I
don't think he's obviously I don't think
he's a Holocaust denier but they're you
know what is the connection yeah Trump
in this I guess well I think the
connection to Trump is that because of
his rhetoric on immigration and not not
even his specific position so much as
just the kind of level of vehement and
comments like you know and I mean yeah
it's true that he didn't say all Mexican
illegal immigrants were rapists but I'd
like the whole oh you know these Mexican
you know Mexico is sending us these
rapists you know kind of stuff I think
it did
send a message to a lot of people on the
kind of gender and laziness phobic
you know parts of the outright that hey
you know this is a guy who thinks the
way we do and I think Ann Coulter is
kind of a conduit there too because
she's you know she's actually engaged
for years in some extremely nasty
rhetoric targeting all sorts of
different people and including
immigrants and she has an open
invitation to come on the show by the
way oh okay okay and you know she became
a big cheerleader for Trump and I mean
the story that I've heard is that
actually it's the success of her
anti-immigration book you know audio
idea was America was what brought what
kind of drove Trump to decide suddenly
to make immigration the biggest year of
his campaign because you never really
know this is kind of the interesting
thing in 2012 he actually criticized
Mitt Romney for doing two
anti-immigration right which is funny I
mean in a way when people talk about
Trump you know being this and that
ideologically I think Trump
ideologically Trump is a trumpet you
know that doesn't make him not dangerous
because you know and an egomaniac who is
you know very close to being president
well I don't know how close right now I
think if neither one of them wins but to
the Trump point yeah I agree I think
he's he's out for his own we don't know
it I don't think we fully understand
what his motivations are which may be
all president yeah I have a degree of
that but what my theory is no more
constantly go man yeah okay sure
absolutely
political standard actually my fear with
with the Trump thing is that it's not I
don't think he's a white nationalist or
something like that
nobody by any estimation but I think
he's allowed for it to suddenly become
it's sort of okay right now look I'm
what you know and I like you I'm a free
speech absolutist so as long as these
people aren't calling to harm for
letting them be out there and I'm not
for banning any of them just like I'm
not for banning Mylo from Twitter and
all that guy but I fear at some level
that were normalizing a certain well
that's yeah I think that is a problem
and I think and that is really why I
felt that it was important to to address
this yeah and you called them out by
those yeah and I have and I really do
have I mean I think Marla was a very
smart guy who's you know done some great
things and you know criticizing and
mocking the social justice warriors I
mean I think it was a really really big
mistake for him to start essentially
normalizing and
jedd amaizing the other these kind of
creepy or segments of the alright right
but but isn't the irony have you seen
them turn on him lately because I've
seen these websites that are now calling
- OH
Nazis show up it and why so much of that
is theater you know I mean I don't know
how many of these people again never
actually get out of the basement so yeah
I think a lot of what goes on will the
outright us Theodora
I mean you know I've gotten threatening
tweets and messages from these people
that I don't really take seriously I
mean it's I think a lot of that is
really just kind of showing off and kind
of being [ __ ] on Twitter you know
when you have a lot of this very violent
rhetoric going on you never know when
it's going to actually you know trickle
down to the wrong person who actually
decides to do something about it they're
not just some tweets and so on so I'm
not gonna say that this is sort of not
dangerous because when you have a lot of
this rhetoric that demonizes people that
calls for violence I mean there's a lot
of rhetoric um calling for you know
retaliation against enemies of Trump
yeah
and I've seen a lot of you know I think
that the rhetorical atmosphere their
rhetorical climate right now
is really is really bad and of course
I'm not gonna blame that entirely on the
alright this may be a good moment so
that's a segue to the regressive okay so
that's where that's exactly where I want
to go with that because my the reason
I've been somewhat sympathetic to
whatever the all right is is that I do
see and I'm not defending the white
nationalist for the purpose of this but
for all the people that are just [ __ ]
posting and upsetting everybody and are
and are sending memes all over the place
and trying to be heard and all that
they're angry at the establishment
fully understand and they're angry at
political correctness and who did that
to them
it was the regressive left it was the
people on the left that silenced
everybody with these false cries of
racism and bigotry so they're they're a
natural reaction and that's why I've
been sort of metallic reaction really
remember actually arguing about this
with Milo like back before he abroad
those articles that were definitely all
right and I'm sure in a kind of serious
way when he was just kind of starting to
kind of dabble and you know apologizing
for the help right and he was basically
saying oh well you see what what's
really going on here is that they want
to challenge these taboos so you know
because these a bit because the the
racist label is constantly being used to
silence conservatives they're actually
trying to kind of make that stigma
meaningless by actually you know saying
things first of all bought bought by
doing this because I do think that you
know the vast majority of people you
know who are not social justice warriors
you know who are not their aggressive
love nonetheless you know quite rightly
loathe and you know to test genuine
racism and bigotry what you're doing by
you know saying this crap is alienating
people who could be the could be right
who could be your allies because you
know they're gonna look at you and say
oh well you know these people really are
racist creeps
you know no thank you we don't really
want anything to do with them so you
know I mean that's really a little bit
like you know like if you're a black
person who wants to you know challenge
negative stereotypes of blacks you're
not gonna do that by you know trying to
embody those I mean it's a little bit
like uh I suppose the year you have some
people and they like the rap community
who kind of do that understood you know
and it's it's stupid when when anti PC
people do it it's you know but
but I totally agree that the the love
bears a lot of responsibility for the
the climate of you know the really
really bad and counterproductive
rhetorical climate don't worry uncouple
some of that from life cuz that's you
know that's why Brice spent so much time
talking about this on the show is that I
want liberalism to right turn to logic
and reason and not always demonizing
everybody how do I do that and is it
almost too late because we now sweater
side gaining power and there yet only
gonna make them that much more scared
the people better right well I don't
think it's too late I mean I think I
don't think we're at the point yet you
know we're not in the Soviet Union we're
not at the point where you can you know
go to prison for you know wrong thing
right but you don't see the linings of
that but we do see the underpinnings of
that I think it's really important for
you know genuine liberals you know what
I would love to see by the way is a kind
of liberal conservative alliance of
reasonable people and I think right now
that is feasible I think we're seeing a
lot of that we're seeing people like you
know Jonathan Chait on the liberal side
for instance speaking out against
political correctness and you know
getting attacked by the progressive love
and I think you know the attacks are
really always the same you know it's
kind of oh like you're just another
white male who doesn't like women and
minorities criticizing you and you know
the only thing worse than a white male
yeah the way he's yeah because actually
if you look at like the article that
Jonathan shade got a talk for it yeah he
was not even talking about criticism
directed at himself he was actually
talking mainly about women and
minorities who were getting attacked and
really nasty ways for being politically
incorrect he was talking about people
like this Muslim student at the
University of Michigan who got really
badly harassed for you know writing
something that mocked political
correctness I mean I think he had like a
bunch of really nasty leaflets dropped
in front of the door of his apartment
and stuff like that so I mean it wasn't
even just people tweeting nasty things
and so on it
really in a way kind of quasi physical
harassment so yeah I think that there is
a there is a movement of both
conservatives and liberals who are very
very ready to reject this and to kind of
try to restore rationality what I would
love to see by the way and this is kind
of my my own personal dream right now
there isn't a single publication like
I've read a lot of publications online I
don't think there was a single
publication that kind of consistently
stands up for a non sort of social
justice and I put this in the word
social justice on quotation marks
because because you know it really is a
kind of you know what passes for social
justice today neo totalitarian called
really yeah it's obsessed with
controlling words and thoughts its
obsessed with identity politics
yeah and it's obsessed with politicizing
every single aspect of life it's like
when you look at for instance the
discussions of culture like movies
whether it's movies video games books
everything in the you know progressive
media like you know vice verge to some
extent of in The Daily Beast which I've
written for in which I think does I mean
The Daily Beast is one of the few that
is I'm kind of completely co-opted by
this and still publishes you know good
stuff but or you know stuff that doesn't
fit that it's identity politics mode
right but a lot of that like all of the
discussion of television everything it's
completely in terms of you know oh well
does this really reflect you know the
true diversity of the population and you
know do we have enough trans people and
that's right you know in business is
this cultural appropriation you know
where does this writer really have the
right to you know talk about this ethnic
group the way that he or she does and
it's all in terms of this ideology and
identity and it's ridiculous
so that and I think what I would love to
see so there's that and there's the
conservative media
the other hand but there isn't a single
publication that could have consistently
embraces a you know kind of true liberal
point of view I mean there are still
some publications like the Atlantic the
Daily Beast that have that point of view
represented but it could exist with a
lot of the really hardcore kind of
ideological you know neo totalitarian as
I would call it yeah and I think that
coexistence very often tends to lead to
the liberal viewpoint being pushed out
because the the social justice people
they're really not interested in
dialogue right they think that the
opposing view Rowena's evil they're
fighting races yes yeah so I mean it's a
little bit like you know you can't
really have a dialogue between Voltaire
on tour c'mon it's gonna end with
Voltaire being burned at the stake right
and so I think what we really need and I
would love to see this you know like
something like the old New Republic for
instance I mean the new New Republic is
this you know lamentable you know shadow
let's for myself where a way that I
don't know if you saw the other day
there they have this really bizarre
essay called what our white writers four
or something and yeah and it contained
the slide which I actually screenshot it
on tweeted that's something like well
for the most part white people have
always been able to do everything they
want to do really are you detached from
reality I never really seriously these
people don't even realize how profoundly
elitist that is because it's like they
think in the gravel road this is a Yale
bride yeah so you think that your
experience as a writer who went to Yale
and because you're white is identical to
the experience of some white guy who
lives in Kentucky and a job
by the way because you people keep
telling him that you know he's a racist
yeah because he is not happy with where
he is right and you know so I think that
you know what I think we really really
need more voices for you know this kind
of liberalism that doesn't you know both
moderate conservatism which I think has
been you know largely edged out these
days by you know the Rush Limbaugh's and
right now there are always very little
about traditional yeah so I think I mean
National Review I think still has some
really good could have a National Review
commentary you know those those
publications I have some really a good
kind of traditional conservative voices
but I think we really really need more
of that and we need more liberal liberal
publications that consistently advance a
liberal yeah you know I really like what
you said about this this new thing
forming because I've been sort of
talking about it a little bit and I've
had a few guests that have mentioned it
and I've been saying for a while that it
seems to me that defending my liberal
values is now but running a conservative
position oh it doesn't make me feel good
yes a that yeah but but I think that
shows that there's a bridge to be built
here I want to back up to something else
that you said which is that everything's
being politicized these days right
because yesterday I saw on Twitter
somebody tweeted that the lead actress
in the show blackish which has double
the ratings I suppose I guess of Tim
Allen's
newer show the one that's on now and it
said that he makes something like 20
times more than him and what the
implication was was somehow that he has
a white man is making more than this
black woman and I think that line in
generally is just a misguided way of
attacking but it was really they were
they were trying to sow some sort of
social injustice really Tim Allen is a
massive star who I think if I'm not
mistaken he's been around from a mini
air he is the only person ever to have a
number one movie number one book and
number one six all at the same way all
the same week so this is a massive star
who's reaping the benefits of being the
headline guy in a city you know Oprah
Winfrey I'm sure
makes a lot more money than you do
people aren't exactly sure how the
YouTube yes she does and I'm a white guy
ah what does that prove there you go
there you go
but but that idea that everything is
politicized it's really dangerous right
as someone that comes from oh absolutely
where everything was politicized
absolutely and and it's it's really
really discouraging to me to see
especially a lot of the cultural
criticism couched completely in these
political terms it's like you know you
can read a random review of some TV show
and suddenly you see a line along the
lines of well of course you know in in
the rape culture of you know modern
American society and women are
systematically suppressed and you know
cannot express their wishes freely and
so you know and it's like it reminds me
of how when I was growing up in the
Soviet Union you know going back to that
experience I had these editions of you
know classics like Shakespeare and
translation and there was a crib
obligatory thing where virtually any
publication of of a classic had to have
a foreword that had to have at least
some passage does not put it in the
proper kind of Marxist context so it was
it says render warning before trigger
right so well trigger warning so much as
kind of an ideological framework that
told you you know what the correct way
to read it was so for instance you know
Shakespeare's King Lear is really about
the emergence of the bourgeoisie and
it's replacement of you know the feudal
family system right and in it really
here and there would be a quote from
either Marx or Lenin and it was funny
because apparently in the Russian
publishing industry I've heard people
actually used to refer to these Marx and
Lenin quotes as locomotives because they
were like pulling through the
publication of the book
and you couldn't get the book published
otherwise so and it's not even
necessarily that the person who wrote
the foreword believes any of that it was
just the sublimity nod to the reigning
ideology and I think we're almost
getting to the point where you look at a
lot of TV movie book reviews in you know
kind of progressive left-of-centre
publications and it's the same kind of
stuff you know you see these you know
references to the the race gender you
know sexuality identity politics
ideology that permeates everything and
and it's scary well yeah especially in
terms of you know gender or gender
issues and relations between men and
women we haven't even gotten to that
yeah you know I've been doing a lot of
writing on gender issues no I know so
unfortunately we're out of time so you
absolutely are gonna come back whether
you like it or not our thing you to come
okay so time next time we're gonna do a
full hour of generation will do all the
genders of feminism and men rights and
all that but I really do love how you
brought this back to where we started
because the themes of being in a society
that are closed we're in an open one now
and someone like you that's lived
through the other side can can see some
of the frameworks of it happening here
so that's why I'm glad that we brought
down I'll give you the last word well I
mean I think you made a really good
point about how we have an open society
and that is suddenly somehow reproducing
a lot of these thought patterns of
closed societies society is where there
is a dominant ideology and I think that
is something that we all have to be very
very leery of I think you know seeing
the world exclusively through a
political slash ideological lens is a
really really limited and skewed way of
looking at the world and it also really
keeps you from looking at the opposing
point of view because you know if if a
point of view that is different from
yours is not just a different point of
view but the enemy you know that is
really not
a that was really not very conducive to
getting a full picture of what's going
on in the world and I think that applies
by the way again to a lot of people on
the right as well as people on the love
I think that you know the right kind of
has its own version of political
correctness I say oh I'm not defending
the right so you know I think we again
and I'm gonna repeat it again I think we
need to and you know my own politics are
kind of moderate libertarian really I'm
not extremely doctrinaire about you know
minimal government I mean I obviously
think less government is better but you
know I'm probably not quite as as
minimalistic about government as some of
my colleagues that reason sure I mean I
think that there are legitimate
disagreements that we can have about you
know the size of government about
welfare programs these are all you know
legitimate subjects for discussion as
long as you know you you understand that
your point of view could be wrong you
know that you're not necessarily right
about everything
and you know unfortunately the the
identity politics are a whole different
ballgame because unlike you know debates
about the nature of the welfare state
for instance identity politics doesn't
tend to put people in boxes identity
politics tends to demonize the
opposition and the this the social
justice ideology that really kind of
seeks to control how people even talk
about identity or related issues and
that's a whole different that's that's a
whole different story and this is where
you know I I don't think it's really
possible to conduct a dialogue with
people who espouse to solitary an
ideology well I'm gonna keep trying and
you absolutely you're coming back we're
we're gonna get interesting as I like to
say on a good interview I don't even
look at these ones I didn't pick them up
once alright it was a pleasure thanks to
coming thank you doing this finally meet
you and I really wanted to this again
we're actually we're real people in more
than 140 characters I can't believe it
for more on Kathy you can check out
Cathy young dot wordpress.com thanks for
watching
you